Hello everyone.
I've got lots of questions here.
And so welcome to the first live
question and answer youtube session that
I'm hosting.
So I'm going to get right into it and
answer some questions.
There's lots coming up on the screen
here.
Um,
Mac one three five,
seven one nine seven,
nine asks,
what does it mean people don't have
ideas,
ideas have people.
Are we okay?
Okay.
Cause I've got an area here.
Sorry about that.
We're going to,
you're going to hear some technical talk
during this because we don't exactly
know what we're doing yet.
Okay.
So what does it mean people don't have
ideas,
ideas have people.
I learned that mostly from young.
In fact,
I think that's virtually a direct quote
from Carl Jung.
One of the things I learned from young
was that it's perfectly reasonable to
think of ideas as something that's
living as,
as a,
as something that's,
that's a lot.
But an idea is something that's alive.
And I think the reason for that is that
the beings that have ideas and so that's
us.
People are alive and we're trying to use
our cognitive ability to further our
living.
And so we create ideas that,
and,
and the,
the purpose of those ideas is to have
them played out in embodiment to have
the Mac that acted out because otherwise
did not have any utility.
And so
we conjure up ideas,
let's say originally,
but they take on a life of their own
over time.
And as they take on a life of their own,
their capacity to dominate someone
increases to the point where the idea is
arguably more powerful than the person.
No.
So if you look at religious ideas,
for example,
maybe you could think of what happened
with regards to Islam and that,
you know,
end up in the latter part of the first
Christian Millennium,
a set of ideas exploded out of one
source and,
and swept through a vast population.
The same thing happened with
Christianity.
In fact,
the same thing is happening with
Christianity right now in China,
China,
in,
in China.
Christianity is spreading faster than it
did in the Roman times.
And definitely something we already
noticed cause our timeframe is small
compared to thousands and thousands of
years.
But ideas have their own goal and their
own perception and their own way of
interacting with the world.
And it's,
it's always possible for them to possess
people.
Why do we feel exposed and vulnerable
when we know and do what we really like?
Your words that Zell H,
well
lots of times people hide behind a shelf
even at cost to them because if the
shell gets criticized and it's not
really that relevant because it doesn't
have any direct bearing on them.
And so if you're not showing your true
self,
so to speak to the world and what you're
showing is something essentially this
false or just constructed and that gets
criticized,
well you can always comfort yourself
with the idea that it's not really you
that's under attack.
So it doesn't wound to the same degree.
Now,
and I mean that's partly why people
protect themselves with falsehoods and
ideologies and,
and
it's an attempt to shield their genuine
vulnerability from assault by the world.
But the problem is is that if you don't
allow that vulnerability to manifest
itself,
then the probability that you're
actually ever going to get what you
really like or even discover what it is
is zero.
So by protecting yourself to that
degree,
you end up losing,
certainly losing it,
what it is that you're most trying to
protect.
I mean,
I don't want to be cavalier about that
because it's understandable that people
attempt to shield their vulnerability
because the vulnerability isn't just
felt,
it's real and people are fragile and you
know,
we're subject to the terrible forces of
nature,
enter the terrible forces of culture.
So
we put all sorts of masks in front of
ourselves so that our exposure is
limited.
People even do that to themselves to
some degree.
If you're front is false enough,
then it's also false to you.
And I suppose people do that to some
degree to protect themselves against
their own self criticisms.
David Guido says,
how can high school teachers best
promote virtue,
cultivate morality,
and tackle the meaning crisis in the
face of an increasingly chaotic,
violent,
and dehumanized future?
Well,
I would say it isn't obvious to me that
the future is increasingly chaotic,
violent,
and dehumanized,
that the past was pretty rough.
Now the future is definitely ill
defined.
We don't know what's going to happen and
I think maybe that's more true in in a
general sense than it ever has been in
the history of mankind.
But I,
I don't necessarily think that there's
reasons to be particularly pessimistic.
However,
the first part of the question I think
is,
is well worth addressing.
How can high school teachers best
promote virtue,
cultivate,
cultivate morality,
and tackle the meaning crisis?
Well,
I think the best way that people in
general promote virtue and cultivate
morality is by promoting virtue and
cultivating morality within their own
light.
But I think that in order to do that for
yourself and then also in order to
transmit that information to your
students,
you have to understand that morality
isn't a sec of injunctions,
of the nature of don't ever do anything
impulsive that you like,
which is generally how Morrell he's put
forth.
You know,
what you think about morality is
something that a puritanical person
might preach.
And that it has to do mostly with self
control and self constraint.
I,
I think that that's a very shallow,
that's a very shell shallow vision of
morality.
I think the way that you convince people
to act morally if that's something that
you're interested in doing is to
meditate on the utility of the truth
because I think the highest form of
morality is following the truth.
So you might say,
well,
why would you bother following?
What's true and answer to that I think
is quite straight forward.
If you follow what's false,
then you're going to end up somewhere
that you weren't planning to go and the
probability that that's going to be good
is low.
Me following what's false,
it's like attempting to use the wrong
map for,
for for the territory that you occupy.
And if your eyes are opening and you pay
attention,
then the probability that you'll be able
to maneuver around the terrible,
sharp obstacles that will emerge in
front of you is that much higher.
And so when you were having a serious
discussion about morality with people,
there's a,
there's a couple of points that you'd
make to begin with.
It's like,
and these were fundamental points.
One would be do you want things to be
better or do you want things to be
worse?
And you might assume that people are
going to automatically answered that.
They'd rather have things better,
but that's not so self evident because
to make things better,
it usually requires that you adopt a
tremendous amount of responsibility and
that's effortful and difficult and
frightening and,
and the buck sort of stops with you,
which is also part of what makes it
terrifying.
But if you do want things to be better
and you have your mind stream and
oriented in that direction,
then
the truth is your best possible guide
because it'll help you get to that
point.
So I think one of the things that people
who talk about morality
failed to understand is that it's not
abstract,
it's practical.
Morality is precisely what's proved to
be most practical,
the longest possible span of time.
Sort of like the,
the moral act is what's best,
all things considered.
And part of the reason that it's
necessary for people to follow
conventional rules is because convention
is part of the wisdom of mankind.
And the wisdom of mankind has basically
said,
you know,
all things considered,
here's a pathway that you can follow
that is going to work out in principle
best for you.
And so,
you know,
one of the,
one of the considerations there,
speaking in terms of convention is,
you know,
the standard path through life,
say in western culture has been to grow
up to form an intimate relationship of
some stability to do something
productive than other people approve of.
And,
and,
and we'll trade with you for,
to raise children and to establish
yourself in a community.
And the reason that that's conventional
morality is because that's not such a
bad deal compared to most of the
alternatives.
And if you can pull all those things off
properly,
then there's a reasonable chance that
you'll at least have a life that isn't
completely full of unbearable suffering
with nothing positive in it.
But there's also the,
there's also a reasonable possibility
that you'll have a good life.
And so then you might want to try to do
that correctly.
Why Act Morally?
Why Act in a virtuous manner?
Because it's in your interest and it's
in every once in else,
everyone else's interest as well.
And so that seems like a good deal.
Now it will mean that you'll have to put
off certain forms of impulsive pleasure.
But the problem often with impulsive
pleasure is that well you,
you,
you have pleasure at haste and you
repented leisure.
And so part of what standard morality is
trying to do is to inform you about how
you might act in the present so that the
present is acceptable.
But so the tomorrow is also good and
next week is also good and next month is
also good and next year is also good for
you and for your family and for your
community,
for this broad swath of humanity.
And partly what you ask people,
you ask high school students is,
well they want to be part of that or did
they want to do something else?
And if they want to do something else,
maybe they want to make things worse
while they should think that through,
because that's just not a very good
plan,
you know,
unless your goal is to make the world a
more miserable place.
And you know,
often people's goals are precisely.
Dot.
Alex fiander asked,
is mindfulness really beneficial or is
it just a trend?
Man,
mostly it's a trend.
Um,
the problem with mindfulness as far as
I'm concerned,
is that it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a word that's like a giant box.
You can put anything you want in it and
claim that that's not only what it is,
but that's what it does.
And so I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I would be very hesitant to make a
blanket statement such,
you know,
like no one practicing mindfulness or
teaching mindfulness is producing any
benefit for their students.
But yeah,
I think mostly it's a,
it's a fat.
So
how can disney produced an architectural
masterpiece in the mid nineties lion
king and then turn around and create
propaganda in the new millennium froze.
That's why Sam Colette,
God,
that's a good question.
But there's an even better question that
goes along with it.
It's like not only could did isn't he
turned around and create propaganda in
the new millennium because I do believe
exactly that that's what frozen is,
but if I remember correctly,
I think that that's the highest grossing
animated movie now that's ever been
made,
so it's not only that they created
propaganda,
it's the people are extraordinarily
hungry for it.
Why would that be?
Well,
one of the ideological motifs in frozen
is that
you know,
the classic idea that
the sleeping beauty needs a prince to
awaken her is observed and old fashioned
and that there are alternative ways of
traveling through life
that don't require the subjugation that
that particular story might appear to
entail.
I think that's really naive beyond
belief because a story like sleeping
beauty
where the feminine is waiting for the
masculine to awaken.
It's true.
It's just as true for men as it is for
women.
It's not about men and women.
Precisely.
It is to some degree.
It's more about the masculine and the
feminine and the feminine part of a man,
which is the part that enables him to
have a relationship with a woman at all,
is awoken by the archetypal masculine
qualities of clarity of mind.
For example,
just as much as the females femininity
is awoken by masculine clarity of mind.
And you can read those old stories and
sleeping beauty in all likelihood.
It's a very little story at multiple
levels simultaneously.
So,
but I,
I think that people want the propaganda
because it tells them that what they
already think is correct
and
that all the old wisdom or much of the
old list them,
it can just be dispensed with and people
can conduct your lives in any manner
that they want.
Well,
that doesn't work.
So
Julian 10 says,
you have said that to study history is
to study oneself and one will be much
more grounded and strong if they do.
So will you please more talk on this,
please talk more on this.
Well,
you know,
it's easy for people to think,
let's say you're 30 years old.
It's easy for you to think that you're
actually 30 years old,
but you're not.
You're in many ways,
at least at one level of analysis,
you're three and a half billion years
old because that's approximately how
long the genetic structure that has
given rise to you,
at least in part has existed.
And you're the consequences of this
massive,
massively extensive evolutionary process
extending back billions of years.
It's conditioned every aspect of you.
And so you're a very,
very ancient creature from a biological
perspective.
And if you don't view yourself across
that entire span of time,
so to speak,
you have the wrong idea about what it
means to be a human being.
And then on the cultural end of things,
while you're deeply shaped and
and inhibited and offered opportunity by
the entire history of human cultural
endeavor,
which is also interacted in the causal
manner with,
with the emergence of our biology across
time.
And if you don't understand history,
then you don't understand who you are
because you're a product of history.
Everything you think someone else
already thought,
every word that you use,
someone else came up with.
And so
and now youth person thinks for example,
that the thoughts that they have or
their thoughts,
but the probability that you're going to
have a thought that's original is
extraordinarily low.
And so just to understand your own
thought process,
you need to be deeply,
you understand your own thought process
far more deeply.
If you are an astute student of history,
you also understand the problems that
confront you in the world.
I mean,
you're born into the world in a
particular historical configuration.
That's an architectural truth.
You know,
your spirit is born into the world when
the world is a certain specific way.
And that certain specific way is also a
consequence of
vast patterns of processes that have
laid themselves out on a historical
timeframe.
I mean,
just a simple example.
I mean a lot of the um,
interpersonal complexities that young
people face say in their,
in their intimate relationships are a
direct consequence of the birth control
pill.
I mean,
that's only been around for 50 years.
So it's not deep history,
but it certainly,
it certainly history.
And if you don't understand that the
birth control burst in on humanity like
app,
like an atomic
bomb,
maybe like a hydrogen bomb,
you don't understand what it is that's
driving your own interpersonal problems.
So there's no difference between
studying history and studying
psychology.
And there's,
there's no difference between studying
history and psychology and,
and trying to understand who you are and
what you should do histories about you.
It's not about the world or it's about
the world and you,
and if you can't see the sense in it,
then you're not approaching it properly.
Or You have bad teachers where you don't
know how to read or something like that
because history is unbearably
interesting.
And so I suppose that's another marker
that you can use to determine whether or
not your attitude towards studying
history is correct.
If you're not fascinated and horrified
by it,
almost beyond belief,
then you're not studying history
properly.
And I think if you were studying it
properly,
you'd never ask why you should study it.
It would,
it would be so evident,
so obvious that it was necessary.
Why did humans enjoy sad stories?
That's Lx yonder.
Well,
I don't know if they actually enjoyed
them,
although I think you could make a case
that they do in sometimes.
Maybe someone's watching a story that's,
that's somewhat sentimental that'll make
them tear up.
And you might say that that's an element
of being sad.
But I would say that's more an element
of being compassionate and participating
in this fictional way in,
in the love and the intimacy that human
beings are capable of.
So you can do that by proxy and that can
certainly produce sentimental emotions
and,
and nostalgic emotions.
And those can be associated with tiers.
But you could go deeper than that and
saying,
well,
people will watch tragic stories.
And that's certainly the case mean any
shakespearian play virtually is,
is tragic in many regards.
And I think part of the reason that
people are,
are compelled to do that is because
we're compelled to understand the
tragedies of our life.
And so to see that tragedy laid out on a
stage,
which means that it's distilled and
amplified in some sense,
is to simultaneously engage in the
problem of wrestling with what it means
to exist in a tragic world.
And any information you can get about
that is going to be well worth the
momentary negative emotion that you
might experience while you're engaged in
the play.
So people like sad stories because life
is often sad and we have to figure out
how to deal with that and stories can
tell you how to deal with it well and
how to deal with it badly.
And uh,
that can be absurdly informative.
If Christianity has much historical
wisdom to offer,
why is it so derided in the academy?
Is this a good thing or a bad thing?
Why Ryan Ross?
Well,
I think that people generally think of
Christianity as
science for stupid people.
It's something like that,
you know,
and it's often reduced to its more
fundamentalist manifestations.
So you know that the straw man version
of Christianity is
fundamentalist protestantism of the
sword that makes the case that the Bible
is literally true and that the cosmos is
roughly several thousand years old.
Well,
it's easy to,
it's easy to make fun of that.
I'm not sure it's so why is to make fun
of it can mean people generally have
reasons for what they believe and
sometimes it's fear and,
and narrow mindedness and ignorance.
But sometimes what might appear to be
fear,
fear and narrow mindedness and ignorance
is actually the attempt to preserve
something of extraordinary,
extraordinary value.
The value of which has not been fully
articulated.
I guess partly I see the,
so there's the,
there's the,
there's the ability for people to
generate the straw man version of
Christianity and then just feel
intelligent by comparing their old
knowledge to that.
And you know,
that's pretty weak I would say.
I think Marxism contributes to it a lot.
I mean,
I think that the universities and our
intellectual life in general is still
saturated with Marxist in new Marxists
presuppositions.
And I really think that's a terrible
thing.
I really don't think that that's any
better than having our intellectual
landscape populated by neo fascist
ideas.
I don't see it from a historical
perspective that there's any reason
whatsoever to assume that neo Marxist
ideas are any more morally appropriate
than neofascist ideas.
Yeah.
And I think a lot of what drives them,
the Neo Marxist analysis of Christianity
is,
some of it's,
some of it's simple mindedness mean the
marxists tend to reduce everything to
power or to economics.
And I mean,
power and economics are important,
but to reduce everything to that is,
is to reduce everything to any one thing
is a mark of a weak mind.
I mean,
most problems multivariant problems,
they're not univariate problems.
I think there's a hatred for the
responsibility that genuine Christianity
lays upon a person.
Because after an architectural level,
I mean if you just,
if you,
if you just speak about this
psychologically,
you don't set,
for example,
the soul is naturally Christian.
It's a hell of a thing to say.
But he had his reasons for saying that.
And part of what he was saying was that,
or what do you believe in,
and Aldous Huxley talked about this a
bit too,
is that
there are elements of Christianity that
have Tiquan conceptualization as far as
it can go.
And that's what makes an architectural
so,
so I can give you an example of that.
So there's a presupposition in
Christianity speaking psychologically
that
human beings make progress by making
sacrifices.
That's a good one.
You see this act it out to begin to,
to begin with,
to some degree in the old testament
where the sacrifices that people make
are,
are genuine,
archaic sacrifices.
If they take something that they're,
that they believe has value,
perhaps a prize animal and burden at
didn't offer it to God.
And the reason that it's burned as far
as I've been able to tell us,
because the archaic conception of the
world was that the world was a flat
disc.
And on top of that disc was a ball and
the ball was the sky,
roughly speaking.
And then outside the ball,
that's where the gods existed.
And I think our cake people believe that
for the same reason that we feel are
when we look up in the night sky,
we don't,
you don't want to make the mistake that
just because people didn't know some of
the things we know now that they were
stupid.
They looked up at the night sky or the
day sky and felt awe and,
and,
and part of the intuition that came
along with that,
or was that
while they were looking at the night sky
with a day start there looking into the
infinite,
and that's a lie very tightly with
divinity.
So there's those ideas going in the
background.
Well,
if you burn something and offer it up to
God,
the smoke rises and God can detect the
quality of your sacrifice and you,
you might think,
well that's again,
that's pretty,
yeah,
simple minded,
but it's not,
it's the dramatic representation of an
unbelievably profound idea.
And the profound idea is that sometimes
in order to make things go properly,
you have to let go of something that you
deeply love or deeply want to do.
And what it means,
what it means to sacrifice is to let
something go in the present so that the
future can be better or to let something
go personally so that other people can
have it better.
And there's no difference between the
idea of sacrifice and the discovery of
the future.
As soon as you discovered the future,
one of the things you realize is that
you have to sacrifice things in the
present so that the future manifests
itself in a more acceptable manner.
So then you think,
well,
that's also an amazing discovery.
Here's the discovery human beings made.
If we change our behavior in the
present,
better things could happen in the
future.
Well,
no other animal really has ever
discovered that.
Okay.
So that's very tightly linked into the
idea of sacrifice.
And so he might say,
well,
you have to sacrifice something of
value.
And so sometimes I ask my students,
a lot of them are second or children of
immigrants.
You know,
what did your parents sacrifice so that
you can go to university?
And I mean,
everyone understands that question.
The students immediately tell me of,
you know,
the things that their parents have done.
They moved from some foreign country.
They spent 18 hours a day working their
selves to the fingers,
to the bone at a laundromat or a dry
cleaner so that their students could
assume that their children could have a
richer and fuller life.
They're sacrificing.
And the sacrifices based on it's based
on faith and the faith in,
it's essentially a form of religious
faith,
but we don't have to get into that
moment.
But the fundamental driving idea is that
the reality is can be positively shaped
by sacrifice.
Well,
that's an amazing idea.
so then you might say,
well,
okay,
the higher quality,
the sacrifice,
the more profound,
the positive effect on the future to
reasonable proposition.
And so then you might say,
what's the most valuable possible
sacrifice and announcer that is long
enviously yourself?
So then you can say,
well,
that means that the ultimate moral
junction,
the ultimate moral injunction is to
sacrifice yourself in a manner that
makes the future better love.
That's the central idea of Christianity.
The central idea,
like the central figure,
mythological figure at the core of
Christianity is the person who
voluntarily sacrifices themself to the
benevolent will of God.
Well,
if you have any sense,
you're terrified of that idea.
And especially if you're,
if you're,
I would say if you're a rationalistic
intellectual or rationalizing
intellectual,
I mean,
who?
Who the hell wants to believe that?
That that's your moral obligation is to
sacrifice yourself for the best.
Well,
God,
you don't know what that means.
I mean the archetypal stories,
it means that you end up crucified.
Well,
there's lots of reasons to be not very
happy,
both that idea,
but then you say,
well,
is the fact that Christian and
Christianity is derided in the academy a
good thing or a bad thing?
Mostly it's a terrible thing.
You know,
it's not like Christianity can't use
some criticism,
although I think,
you know,
nature in many ways,
nature took care of that for us.
But
mostly I think what we're doing in the
academy is running as fast as we can
from the responsibility of bearing our
culture and we're diversifying it.
And we were using any number of
appalling rationalizations and
ideological maneuvers to try to not only
make that acceptable personally,
but to proselytize about it to others.
You know,
the,
the more,
I wouldn't say cynical maybe of what the
more cynical part of me sometimes thinks
that the universities now these students
more harm than good,
especially on the humanities because
they take students at a very formative
period of their life when they're all in
their belief systems and their ability
to identify strongly with life are
already somebody questioned because they
exist in a culture that speak badly
fractured and they take those kids and
they,
you know,
they expose them to ideas that are
absolutely destructive and it's not
about having anything against ideas like
that.
Reading Nicha for example is org or
reading dusty Yefsky.
I mean that can be a very destructive
act but the purpose of each is writing
and Dostoyevsky's writing.
It's not to destroy,
it's to remove detritus so that
something new can spring forth.
And I'm sorry,
I just don't really see that happening
in the universities.
I think there are too cynical and I
think that there's also a strong streak
of serious anti humanity among moderate
intellectuals and that's been the case
for at least a hundred years.
You hear people saying,
you know,
like,
I think this was a statement from the
club of Rome,
the people who are so concerned about
population explosion back in the mid
1960s that the world would be better off
if there were fewer people on it or
maybe that there were no people on it.
Well,
man,
you can't say anything that's more
appalling than that.
You know,
if you said the planet would be better
off if there were fewer black people on
it,
it's like,
well no one's going to put up with that.
Or the planet would be better off if
there were fewer European colonizers on
it.
Well,
you might be able to get away with that
a little bit more,
but probably not.
But as long as your
sentiments expand,
extend to humanity as a whole,
it's perfectly reasonable for you to say
something like that.
And that's the most horrific thing you
could possibly say.
I mean,
the kids who go into high schools and
shoot them up and call them body kids,
and that's certainly what they believe.
The planet would be a lot better off if
there were fewer people on it.
Maybe we'll take a few steps in that
direction.
So
Bob Smith says,
nice jacket.
Thank you Paul.
Appreciate that.
All right.
Can you explain each just general
philosophy and some of his most famous
ideas?
He's really hard to comprehend.
Nature's general philosophy.
I probably can't do that.
I've been putting together with my
students here,
right?
I've been starting to plan a seminar on
existentialism and which would focus a
lot on Nietzsche and Dostoevsky.
I think each just so damn complicated
that you can't really do that.
I don't think you can explain niches.
General Philosophy.
First of all,
it wasn't really a systematizer.
He,
he,
uh,
was skeptical of systematizer.
It's very difficult to distill someone
who's not a systematizer into,
you know,
a few general principles.
The thing is with,
with,
with some of the greatest thinkers,
you actually have to read what they
wrote.
You have to read the original writings
because the,
the brilliance is encapsulated in the
original writings and they can't be
condensed.
So,
so,
let's see.
Can I do any better than that?
Can I explain each his general
philosophy?
Truth serves life.
That's a good one.
And I guess we could unpack that a
little bit.
To me,
that's a good example of exactly what I
need you to.
So staggeringly brilliant.
One of the things he presumes when he
makes a statement like that is that a
human being is in
an existential situation that's
characterized by the necessity of
determining what he or she will actually
accept as truth.
You know,
you might say,
well,
truth is something you can prove and
that's how you know it's true.
But unfortunately it's not that simple
because you have to decide what criteria
you're going to accept.
There's proof and there's an act of
faith in that.
And there's an enabling were that
argument seems to be lacking.
And this is the famous is ot conundrum
that David Hume described is,
okay,
well let's say that you use science to
lay out a very detailed description of
the nature of the objective world.
Well,
that still doesn't mean that you know
how to act in that world.
And that's a big problem.
It might be a fundamental problem if the
fundamental problem of people isn't what
is the nature of the objective world
thought?
How is it that you should conduct
yourself while you're alive?
Well,
neat you to believe that
the fundamental question was how you
should conduct yourself while you're
alive.
How should you act?
And then I would say that's the
fundamental question of meaning and
science can inform you,
but it can't really solve that problem
for you.
And that's a problem.
And then science also has this other
terrible attribute.
Some sense,
which is that
because science can't solve the problem
of how you should act in the world,
it
impels people towards conclusion that
there is no answer to the question,
how should you act in the world?
And so that way that opens up a door to
nihilism and I was,
is,
is it's destructive.
It,
it does not facilitate life.
In fact,
it has the opposite effect.
It takes the spirit of the people,
it takes the motivation out of people,
it makes them bitter,
it makes them resentful,
it makes them hateful.
It's not a good thing.
Also niches,
primarily concerned in some sense with
how to act,
and part of the reason that he
decomposes Christianity to the degree
that he does this because he believed
that Christianity
was a very,
very serious attempt to answer the
question,
how should you act?
And he also believed that it had become
fatally flawed for a variety of reasons,
at least in its typical societally
socially instantiated forms.
So he took it upon himself to subject it
to a criticism.
But I've always thought I've Nicha.
It's a terrible image,
but I've always thought Nietzsche has
like a magnet in a wound.
It's like what he's doing is clearing
away dead and diseased tissues so that
something else can live and it's a
terrible thing to watch.
It's a terrible thing to apprehend and
it's,
it's a terribly destructive thing to
involve yourself in these niches.
He said he philosophize with the hammer
and that's certainly true,
but he was trying to clear the path for
something new and that that's something
new.
He was trying to formulate with his
consumption such as like this,
the,
the superman that the next version of
human beings so to speak.
And he thought of them as people who
would create their own values
and if that would be the way forward,
oh,
is the wreckage of Christianity,
let's say.
Oh,
I think Nisha was wrong about that.
And I say that with all due respect,
believe me,
and I say a cautiously and I don't think
it's an original idea of my own,
that nature was wrong.
And I think the reason that he was
wrong,
just because people don't create value,
say discover them or maybe they cocreate
them,
but you can't create values
by conjuring them out of nonexistence.
You could say if you were scientifically
minded,
that values are in some sense,
arbitrary.
And then if you believe that values are
arbitrary,
you might then believe that people could
create them.
Oh,
there's nothing but values aren't
arbitrary.
And most of the time people discover
them
and maybe they cocreate the,
and one of the reasons that I so have
been so attracted to use thinking is
because young is in many ways a
Nietzschean,
a student of nature,
also a student of Freud,
but more primarily a student of nature
and s lifelong endeavor
was to understand what the way forward
might be given the situation that needs
you to describe and the situation that
needs you to described in some sense was
that Christianity laid so much emphasis
on truth that it ended up undermining
its own axiomatic presuppositions.
And so then you thought following it
needs you well,
okay,
in principle we have to create new
values.
But that that's partly why you even got
so interested in the unconscious because
one of the things he found particular in
his analysis of the collective
unconscious that was that the values
that Nietzsche thought people should
create were actually lying dormant in
well in our imagination.
That's one way of thinking about it
because that's a good way of thinking
about the collective unconscious and
that it was a return to the deepest that
the way forward in terms of the
generation of new value was,
was a return to the deepest recesses of
human existence and a rediscovery of
what was actually there.
I touched on that a little bit today
when I was talking about the necessity
for sacrifice,
like there's an archetypal idea that the
savior,
the Messiah is,
is by definition the person who was
willing to sacrifice him or herself for
the ultimate good,
whatever that happens to be and if
that's the appropriate pathway forward.
Well that's,
that's an art degree teak of
Christianity and I,
and I think that you almost right.
I think he's correct.
That's a terrible thing to say because I
mean yoga is such a radical thinker that
it's,
it's funny because yoga is subject to a
lot of criticism.
I mean,
I read Richard [inaudible] book on
Nisha,
I think it was called the area in Christ
and nowell basically who I think was a
very is or was,
I'm very resentful person.
Um,
I think he did a hatchet job on you.
He,
he the cover of his book made Yo look
like it was a Nazi.
I mean how cheap cheap shot that is.
But you know,
he accused yoga basically fomenting a
cult and I read no book and it just made
me laugh because what you was actually
up to is so much worse so to speak.
Then merely starting a cult.
It's like accusing and ax murder of,
of,
of uh,
of what
annoying,
annoying his pet cat.
You know,
it's that the differences that
extensive,
the sorts of things that Ewan was
actually messing around with are so
complicated and terrible compared to
just building a little cult that,
you know,
it's absolutely clear that Noah had no
idea what he was talking about.
He only said it like nature.
Like Dostoevsky is that terrifying
person.
And I think part of the reason that you
don't use not well regarded in the
academy and also my Christianity is
subject to such continual rationalist
and criticism is because people open up
and take one look at what he's doing and
either just don't get it at all or they
get a little bit of it.
It scares them so badly.
They think there's no damn way I'm going
there and,
and I can really understand that.
I think,
I think anybody with any sense would be
very,
very careful about trying to figure out
what Dean was talking about.
It
is cognitive behavioral,
a sorry here
I missed that.
Sorry about that.
It's a good idea to believe in
something.
Healthy delusions like Karma or life
after death.
That's Danny Wall socket.
Well there is a whole line of social
psychology that was very popular about
15 years ago.
In fact,
the most cited social psychological
paper ever written was about the
necessity of positive illusions.
You know,
the basic hypothesis was life was so
tragic and dismal that unless you
bolstered yourself against it with,
you know,
defensible optimists and I suppose if
you were being charitable or just
positive illusions lies is what I think
are that life would actually be a
tolerable.
And I think that's unbelievably
nihilistic and vicious philosophy.
I think the fact that that was actually
seriously put forward by,
by a generation of social psychologists
as a medication for the modern disease
of meaning,
it is an absolute indictment of the
entire field.
Um,
no,
there's nothing about illusions that are
healthy,
but that doesn't mean that cynicism and
despair are forms of truth or that
nihilism is a form of truth.
There's no such thing as healthy
delusions.
No.
You know,
any wall song consent,
it's like Karma.
Well,
I didn't know Karma is a healthy
delusion and I'm not so sure about,
I
mean there's some elements of Karma that
I think are extremely interesting from a
psychological perspective and we can
scrap the incarnation element of it
because I,
well for obviously at least for the sake
of simplicity,
but I believe in Karma.
I think that no one gets away with
anything ever.
I think every single thing you do that
is the moral cause in the moral thing is
an attempt to work the structure of
reality.
Everything you do that's immoral,
comes back to haunt you.
And it generally comes back in multiply
form.
Now that doesn't mean you'll be able to
drive the costs of connections.
Like you might've done something immoral
who knows five years ago and that
produced like a crack in the structure
of your being and like it's five years
later and all sorts of things are
falling into that crack.
And you have no idea that that initial
act was what produced this know
cascading consequences events.
But that doesn't mean it didn't.
So
what did [inaudible] mean by revolt in
the myth of Sisyphus?
What are some ways to revolt without
being destructive or should one simply
be a good app?
Thank you.
Well that's 19 k Mitch.
Well the first thing I should say,
how bad is it not those so simple to be
a good aunt.
Like I think being a good aunt is better
than just being a chaotic.
And,
and useless aunt.
And so you should probably go from
chaotic and useless and two good.
And that's a process of maturation.
That's what happens when you're,
you know,
you move from being a child to an
adolescent,
to a young adult.
You adopt the strictures and
responsibilities of your culture to
discipline yourself.
Now,
if you stop at the point where you're a
good aunt,
while then I think,
you know,
that's not so good then,
then you're,
you're an Avatar of the pathologies of
your culture as well as an Avatar of the
virtues of your culture.
So,
but you,
you,
it's fighting against mirror
enculturation is,
that's,
that's not virtue,
that's failure.
That's just failure to mature.
You know,
that was actually one of Nietzsche's
questions of conscience.
Um,
are you leading or are you just running
away?
Well,
the answer that almost always is he
running away.
You might think you're leading,
but the probability that you're leaving,
especially if you haven't seriously
considered the possibility that you're
running away,
it's like really?
What's the,
what's the chances if you,
if you really think about us,
not that easy lead and it's pretty easy
to run away.
So if you're not doing what other people
are doing,
you're probably running away.
And you might say,
well that's pretty rough.
It's like fair enough.
You know,
if you've got some absolute,
the unique destiny that you have to
manifest more power to you.
Um,
but
most of the time what I see are people
who think they have a unique destiny and
really what they're doing is wandering
off the beat batch into some thorn
written ditch where things are not going
to be good for them.
So
what are some ways to revolt without
being distracted?
Revolt against what?
That'd be the question.
I mean,
it's a very,
you could try revolting against your
lack of discipline.
Like that's good.
That's a war.
If you want a war,
maybe you do because people need war.
You know,
I think it was William James who said
that people need a moral equivalent to
war.
I think that's what [inaudible] was
trying to discover,
by the way,
the moral equivalent to war,
and I think he did discover it as well.
And that's tied up with the idea of
sacrifice.
If you want to revoke,
you should revolt against your own
pathology and inadequacy and uselessness
and resentment and cruelty and blindness
and yeah,
you could have a war against,
you could revolt against that.
That gives you something to do.
Pete,
Professor Mra,
people are often quite smart.
Why did they have this strong tendency
towards atheism?
Oh,
well,
you know people who are,
have smart,
good atheistic right away because you
know,
it's obvious who really believe in God.
You believe in an old man and this guy,
you already think the world's least
7,000 years old.
It's like,
do you really believe Christ turned wine
into water?
You know,
no one who wasn't foolish would believe
that.
While that's the statement of someone
who's,
I guess who's smart enough to start to
notice something about what people
believe,
but you know,
they're 10 steps along out 50,000 mile
journey.
So,
and then the other thing,
I already mentioned this about atheism,
people like to think that the reason
their atheistic is because they're clear
headed and rational.
It's like,
well first of all,
know,
probably they're not.
Because how often do you meet someone
who's clear headed and rational?
Like being psychoanalytically minded?
I'm always way more likely to look for
the dark reason that someone is doing
something rather than the light reason.
You know,
the reason that's moving them towards
the light because it's hard to move
towards the light.
And so I would say most of the time
people are atheistic.
Well,
it's kind of,
it's fashionable in some silicon said
fashion way to Vr to revolt if you're
rational and if you're kind of an
intellectual.
Um,
but also you can just dispense with
responsibility if you're atheistic.
And I think that's 90% of the reason
that it's,
especially in the modern world,
that's why people are proponents of
atheism.
You know,
or they have some particular hatred for
the church.
I think Richard Dawkins has a particular
hatred for the church.
I would,
I've thought about this many times.
I would swear that something happened to
him when he was a kid that wasn't good
and that the church was involved because
he has such an animus against the
church.
It's that,
that it,
it,
it possesses him.
There's a reason for that.
All right,
so let's see here.
That's,
can you explain why the conventional
wisdom about each and people are so at
odds with your ideas about each of
people.
But yeah,
that's Harold.
Boom.
I can explain that.
People like to think they're smart and
they like,
and the easiest way to think you're
smart in many ways is to think that
other people aren't.
And so we think,
well,
the people who came before us all these
thousands of centuries,
you know,
they just didn't know what we knew.
Well,
there are cultures didn't have the same
degree of staggering technological
capacity that our skin,
but that didn't mean that they were
stupid.
I mean you throw the average person back
into ancient Athens,
they're not gonna last very long.
It's lack of respect.
And you know,
that is a definite hallmark of water
culture is that you can hardly even
tell.
You know,
you can hardly even say,
well being respectful.
It sounds like you're from 19
be respectful.
Well
if you're not,
if you don't want to be nihilistic,
you better be respectful because
yeah,
being nihilistic and having respect for
nothing are exactly the same thing.
So you could start by having some
respect for your ancestors and try and
figure out what the hell they were
talking about.
He read the Old Testament for example.
It's a very weird book.
It's a very,
very,
very weird book.
Lots of people wrote it,
lots of people and it did.
It got sequenced together and turned
into this volume for,
for reasons that we just can't
understand.
It's our collective work of the human
imagination and people read it.
So simple.
It's such a simple minded way.
They read it like fundamentalist,
like simple minded.
Fundamentalist Protestants.
Think about science.
No,
the fundamentalist Protestants think the
Bible is literally true.
Science is literally true.
Doris,
the Bible is science.
Well,
you know,
no,
the people who wrote the Bible word
scientist,
that's just not how it works.
But then the,
the,
like the modern critics of religious
thinking of traditional religious
thinking,
they're just,
they're the same.
They do the same thing except backwards.
They say,
no,
religion was science.
It's just bad sides.
And so,
you know,
we don't have pay any attention to it.
Well,
it's not science,
it's something else.
It's ethics,
it's morality,
it's drama,
it's all of that and dramas about how to
live and religious drama is,
it's a definitional issue.
There's nothing deeper than religious
drama.
And the reason for that is that depth
defines what's religious.
And like I know this firsthand hardly
because in my clinical practice,
like I often see people who are in
terrible,
terrible trouble and often that trouble
is ethical and if the trouble they're in
is bad enough,
there's no other language to
conceptualize it in.
Isn't religious because the religious
language comes into its own.
When you're dealing with problems.
Normally we have life and death,
but literally of Heaven and Hell and you
know,
modern people think,
well there's no such thing as heaven and
there's no such thing as hell.
It's like,
okay fine,
there's no such thing as heaven,
let's accept that.
But if you think there's no such thing
as hell,
like
I can't see how someone who's educated
would ever dare to make that claim.
Like
after everything that happened to us in
the 20th century,
I can't see that someone could ever say
that there's no such thing as hell
without being terrified that a bolt of
lightning would obliterate them on the
spot.
No.
Hell is real.
And if you want to talk about use
religious language and if you want to
figure out how to get away from hell,
you use religious language.
And that's what religious language is
for.
So you know the,
the,
that's actually understandable.
Now I would say if,
if it,
if you want to learn about this,
you can,
you can read nature,
you can read Dostoyevsky you can read
young.
It's hard.
You can read young student,
Eric Normand,
Eric Norman was a genius.
Like I wanted this information is there
waiting for people to,
to begin to understand it.
But it's hard slog again.
And part of the problem is is that you
get to hell way before you get to have,
you know,
and one of the things youngest sometimes
conceptualized as a new age thinker,
I think that's absurd.
I think it's,
it's,
it's the platelet observe,
one of his fundamental propositions is
that if you follow a meaningful and
truthful path that will take you to the
worst place you can imagine.
And then possibly having gone there,
the journey uphill,
you know,
towards the light can begin in earnest.
Well,
who wants that?
no one,
if they have any sense,
but you know,
young also made another statement which,
which really taught me to the bone when
I first understood it,
he said,
yeah,
anything you don't thoroughly
understand,
you act out in the world as fate.
And so one of the,
one of the lessons I took away from that
is then,
you know,
if you don't want hell to manifest
itself in the world,
then you better understand your role in
producing it.
And I would say that's actually the
primary religious injunction.
And I would also say that that's a big
part of the reason why belief systems
such as Christianity.
I'm talking mostly about Christianity
because that's what I'm most familiar
with.
But,
and also because it's,
it's definitely out the fin on the
foundation of Western civilization
actually quite a fan of Western
civilization.
I mean,
the fundamental moral injunction is in
Christianity or one of them.
I mean they're all tangled together,
I guess to some degree it's like you
want to constrain hell within yourself.
Well,
that's no joke man.
I mean,
you know,
one of what,
another thing I learned from Yoga and
from Nietzsche was that if you,
if you,
if you look at the sorts of things that
happen,
saying now she Germany or,
or,
or in the Soviet Union or in Mao's China
or that are still happening around the
world where they're systematic torture
and persecution of millions and millions
of people,
where,
where the entire state was devoted
towards making things as bad as they can
possibly be and then making them even
worse after that is that people played a
role in that and they were people like
you.
And that means that people like you play
a role in that.
And so then the question is what's your
role and is that the game that you want
to be playing?
Well,
that's a serious question because it is
people like you who were responsible for
that.
And it means that to the degree that
you're a person and you don't want that
to happen anymore,
you have to sort that out within
yourself.
So I can,
I can explain it.
I think I'll close with this another
deeply religious idea.
There's another idea.
This is an archetypal idea about the
image of the savior,
the Messiah.
The Messiah is the person who takes the
sins of the world onto himself.
That's a classic archetypal idea.
It's like what does that mean?
It means that you look for the
motivations that drove Hitler in
yourself because they were there
and that's what it means to take the
sins of the world onto yourself.
It means that you have to view yourself
as the perpetrator of archetypical evil.
You know,
one of the things you said for example,
what's that?
If you,
if you take a small moral failing that a
person manifests and you dig into that
as deeply as you can,
you end up in the center of health,
like the roots of that unethical
behavior go all the way down to the,
to the,
to the archetype and in my experience,
docs being true.
That's,
that's right.
That's why people want to have
conversations about this sort of thing.
Can you see it happening in,
in,
in intimate relationships all the time
where there are things that the two
people who were involved in the
relationship,
we'll just not talk about why it's cause
they don't want to go there.
And where is it that they don't want to
go?
They don't want to get to the bottom of
things.
Well,
no wonder because you know,
that's an archetypal idea to hell is a
pit.
It's at the bottom of things.
It's like,
yeah,
that is where it is and you have to go
there.
If you want a straight things out,
it's like who the hell wants to do that?
Well,
the alternative is that it plays itself
out in the world and we've seen that and
that doesn't look like a good idea to
me.
Well,
I guess we should probably end there
because I'm getting fuzzy minded then
stuff.
That's always a good time to stop.
So thank you very much for tuning in and
if this seems to have been successful,
kind of had a slow start as far as I was
concerned.
I was kind of muddled headed to begin
with.
But,
uh,
you know,
maybe we'll edit all that out anyways,
I'm thinking about doing this on a
regular basis,
so,
you know,
let me know what you think and,
and,
uh,
we'll see how many people watch it and
we'll see what happens.
And thanks to all my Iras because I've
learned some research assistants here
who already helping me out with this.
So a,
mastering the technology and figuring
out what to do with youtube.
So thank you very much for tuning in
and,
uh,
hopefully I'll see you again.
Ciao.